words
[Applause]
[Music]
story in five words bull rides shotgun
in Nebraska as you can see there's a
video of a bull riding shotgun in
Nebraska guy got pulled over he's in
trouble
Charlie I'm going straight to you bud
because well you famously or at least
famously in my mind because I think
about every time I see you you win on
America's Newsroom after getting kicked
on the face by a horse I don't know if
you guys know about this but we have a
photo right we have a look at that there
it is there it is and I love this I
respect it so much because you were like
you know what this doesn't interfere
with my ability to give my opinion on
the news
hey hey it's it's my mind you just
showed up and you thought someone wasn't
gonna be like are you good
I really did I actually I really I
really did think that maybe they won't
notice
they'll notice wait did they think well
there wasn't a makeup person
here and I was like yeah I'm sure if I
just hold my head right
and then Dana is like Charlie what in
the hell is wrong with you I was like oh
is this obvious I'm sorry it just showed
up and didn't mention it yeah
my wife was out of town that's what
that's how it is
no exactly no it's all right
that was a lot like an iron it was
awesome it was all her fault yeah it was
out of town yeah you have to be more
careful and then the the other problem
was I was riding around with and nobody
else was there in the car because I
wanted to know I saw the video was this
how that happened oh no but you gotta
admire this guy I mean the fact that he
got pulled over do we live in a free
country anymore and this is not even a
Trans Am
this guy took a welder and cut half of
the roof off to accommodate his his
friend that is true American Ingenuity
and engineering
I know why he got pulled over though
did you think about maybe not going on
America's Newsroom
hey look if I have a job to do I'm going
to get the job I will always get the job
done I understand why he got pulled over
yes
the police were confused because his
license plate clearly says boy and a dog
I noticed everything that's amazing
listen I I lived I went to school in
Nebraska this is awesome this guy loves
this bull I know a little bit of a back
story so this bull this Watusi bull
named howdy Duty a tour that's his name
they travel around the parades and stuff
and well parades are not paying like
they used to so he lost the truck in the
trailer so what he did was he and his he
cares about his bull no the bull
obviously can't fit a seat belt but he
has a seat gate you put the gate a
little rope right there it's very cool
the other reason why he got pulled over
was as you can see the bull his head is
facing this way but the back end of the
bull is clearly not in the car and Bulls
much like horses and President Biden
just go whenever they want to
he was given a citation and he went home
DeVito
uh if I were the bull I'd be looking at
the horns on the front of that hood
saying where did you get those because
I'd say I think this shows the lens
white people have to go do to get pulled
over in the United States
dad jokes
that when he he the cop he could say uh
why'd you pull me over yeah
and that when he got the ticket he could
say this is
Julie anything to add and or questions
for Charlie Hart
well no well yes
no I think that we're missing the big
part of this story and it's where the
back of the bull was positioned the
cleanup that is going to be involved can
we please just put up the picture
because I asked the producers to put
together a picture they thought it might
be too graphic but Tyrus you notice
everything right well did you notice the
amount of crap on the back of that car
this poor bull needs Pepto or medicine
I mean he literally had the runs like
the guy needs to feed him more fiber oh
look at the car we're always covering
the real news here yeah all right don't
go away we're gonna be wrong hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else